so over in pennsylvania they've
announced that allegheny county is not
going to begin counting about 30 000
ballots
until tomorrow these systems are just
broken they're just broken i mean the
possibility of undermining public
confidence is so unbelievably high when
you delay the counts
this way when you're not counting
through the night when you are delaying
the counts
and obviously it's because of this
patchwork of laws that have been created
and that's not just on democrats that's
on republicans
it was on republicans in wisconsin it's
on republicans to a certain extent in
arizona
right well but a lot of the messes that
are created here are bipartisan messes
and they require an actual cleanup
there's a reason that florida runs this
thing
uh really tightly runs this runs a
really clean ship when it comes to the
voting count
according to chris potter the reason why
allegheny county which includes
areas uh that are very democratic and
and could make up the difference
for the uh for for joe biden against
donald trump and pennsylvania right now
trump holds a very slim lead in
pennsylvania
and the reason that allegheny county
apparently is being delayed
is because the ballots in question
according chris potter who's a reporter
for wesa
requires special attention the vast
majority up to 29 000 involve the
situation
where a vendor sent the wrong ballots to
voters and then had to reissue new
ballots with the correct races
the challenge is there are now voters
who have two ballots one with the wrong
races so you have to give those ballots
a special scrutiny to make sure that a
people don't vote twice
and b if they just send in the old one
they don't vote in races they aren't
eligible for so you can't just scan them
along
with the rest other ballots in the pot
include those that don't scan for
whatever reason
like when an atm won't process the
amount of a check you want to deposit so
you have to bring it into the bank
office
when ballots require special scrutiny
the county records at the vote through a
return board whose members are sworn in
for that purpose the board reviews the
results tallied up by election workers
after polls close
but also addresses provisional ballots
military ballots etc
the board's members are set to be sworn
in tomorrow the friday after election
day
there's nothing nefarious here the the
county's gop chair is comfortable with
the process this is also not people just
taking a day off
the other factor is the county has to
wait until friday for mail-in ballots to
come in
that were postmarked by election day
that whole situation was adjudicated by
the courts as far as the complaints that
republicans have
about ballots coming in after election
day that were not postmarked those
ballots are in fact being sequestered
they're being kept separate from the
other ballots
uh and so if the supreme court has to
rule on that the supreme court will rule
on that
as well there are a lot of rumors out
there right now regarding the
possibility of voter irregularities
and voter fraud this is exacerbated by
the fact that the
trump team is filing some fairly well
predicated lawsuits apparently there's
one lawsuit in pennsylvania that they
just had granted it was an injunction
forcing
the the trump ballot watchers to be
allowed
into the balloting areas
so this is uh it's all a mess i mean i
think the short story here is is
all a ed morrissey of
hot air at least who is obviously
conservative he says no one in
pennsylvania is gold bricking this
process now with the nation focused on
them and the specter of florida 2000 in
our peripheral vision meanwhile
georgia is getting tighter and tighter
so the current count
in georgia is putting biden within
striking distance
of of president trump the the trump team
says that they are not particularly
worried
about georgia at this point but things
are incredibly incredibly close as in
like
12 000 votes close okay and
a lot of the ballots that are that are
coming in are
are coming in from particularly
democratic areas
so team trump is uh attempting to now
cure ballots apparently
uh there are about eight thousand
ballots that they're attempting to kill
people who
put in their ballot but there was a
mistake on the ballot and it's another
trying to fix those
according to the new york times the
presidential race in georgia appeared
headed for a photo finish as former vp
joe biden steadily gained ground on
president trump
the victor will be awarded 16 electoral
votes and with the presidency presumably
biden began wednesday morning
approximately a hundred thousand votes
behind trump but as county elections
workers
around the state continued the laborious
tabulation of absentee ballots
into thursday morning trump's lead
narrowed to 23 000 votes or 0.5
there's an automatic recount provision
if the margin is 0.5
or less fulton county is of course where
a lot of these votes are coming from and
that is
home to most of atlanta
apparently according to brad
raffensberger the georgia secretary of
state who is a republican
he said that as of 10 15 p.m wednesday
about 90 000 ballots still needed to be
counted more of a third of them
were in fulton into counties as well
so all of this is too close to comfort
for for for anybody
at this point meanwhile in nevada
we have reached the end of the road for
today apparently there will be no new
announcements of
the ballading in nevada nevada reported
another round of votes
it showed biden's lead expanding from
about 7 600 votes to more than 10 000
votes in nevada that's out of about 1.2
million votes that have already been
counted
trump's lead in pennsylvania has also
been narrowing
it fell to about 130 000 votes or 2.1
percent in pennsylvania
as of late this morning there were still
almost 600 000 mail-in ballots to remain
counted most of the mail-in ballots
remain in philadelphia county which of
course is heavy democratic territory
followed by chester county that's a
county that turned blue in 2016 and then
allegheny county
and that is the the one that we've been
talking about in terms of the the pause
that has been put
uh on hold right now so bottom line is
this
it is all a mess and we're all gonna
have to wait and we're all just gonna
have to get over it
now this does not mean that there are
not
plausible allegations of voter fraud or
voter irregularity it means that the
margins right here
would have to be very very narrow for
voter fraud or voter irregularity
to be the deciding factor in all of this
we're gonna find out by tomorrow i think
that by tomorrow midday
we're gonna know exactly where we stand
in the vast majority of these states
arizona remains a toss-up state there's
apparently going to be a late night dump
by the arizona secretary of state
of data team trump seems pretty
confident that they are actually going
to overwhelm the democrats in arizona
with the late-breaking ballot and take
over there now one of the things that
you've heard from the media
is that it is ridiculous that trump is
wanting the votes to be counted in
arizona but he wants the votes counted
he wants the the votes paused in
philadelphia there's a reason for that
in one he believes that there is a
well-predicated legal challenge and when
he believes that there is not or at
least his legal team does
the fact is that in arizona there has
yet to be real
accusations of voter impropriety the
only one that i've heard is sharpiegate
and it turns out that that is likely
untrue
but in pennsylvania there are serious
questions to be asked about poll
watchers there are questions to be asked
about the standards that are being
applied right now as to which ballots
get counted and which ones don't
get counted one thing is clear in
arizona that's the fox news absolutely
screwed up so fox news may end up being
right
about calling arizona in favor of biden
when all is said and done but they
called it tuesday night and that was
just absolutely wrong even nate silver
was like this is crazy fox needs to
retract that call so nate silver tweeted
that out yesterday
he said that in his own opinion he said
i don't know i guess i'd say bye don't
win arizona if you force me to pick i
sure as heck don't think the state
should have been called by anyone i
think the calls that were previously
made should be retracted now
a trump campaign official went on fox
news and reamed fox news for the early
arizona call
again that came on tuesday night as this
narrows there is going to be great
pressure on you guys
to be honest with you fox news to
rescind your call it was
it was a premature call you know we were
livid about the fact that you and then
the ap
made that call there are seven
organizations that
call states on election night from time
to time seven
five of those seven did not make that
call
okay exactly we got it and i agree i
don't want to be in a position
this is going to lead john biden to
falsely declare himself the president
elect at some point understood okay so
fox news certainly should not have
called it that early i think that is
pretty obvious to everybody including
many of the pollsters so arizona again
up for grabs pennsylvania up for grabs
georgia up for grabs it looks like
michigan has trended against trump so
michigan is probably gone
wisconsin has trended against trump that
is a 20 000 vote margin so that one is
probably gone
trump has filed lawsuits in wisconsin to
demand a recount the recount
is unlikely to shift 20 000 votes most
recounts may shift a couple of hundred
votes
and that's when you start to get into
real voter fraud territory right when
you're talking about hundreds of votes
like it was in norm coleman vs al
franken
and suddenly ballots are magically
discovered like
three weeks after an election that's
when you start to get real suspicious
but to shift tens of thousands of votes
obviously would be a heavier a heavier
lift
so right now all i can counsel is
patience a little bit of patience here
i know that democrats don't want to
allow for that democrats are very
impatient
they're saying it's time to declare
let's just declare this thing the
problem with that
is that if you actually would like to
see the american public trust the
outcome you need to wait it out
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content